BROTHER.
THIS COMES AS KIM JONG-UN AND
HIS INNER CIRCLE ARE PROJECTING
STARTLING NEW IMAGES OF POWER.
AN ENORMOUS FANFARE, KIM JONG-UN
STRIDES CONFIDENTLY PAST HIS
GENERALS, WAVES FROM A PLATFORM
ABOVE THE SQUARE IN PYONGYANG.
HUNDREDS CHANT THE LEADER'S
NAME.
THE CLOSE OF WORKERS PARTY
CONGRESS, SENDING A POWERFUL
MESSAGE OF STRENGTH HE WANTS TO
PROJECT.
PART OF THAT MESSAGE, THIS IS A
HIP AND MODERN REGIME, SHOW
CASED BY A PERFORMANCE OF HIS
HANDPICKED ALL GIRL BAND.
THERE WERE YEARBOOK STYLE PHOTOS
OF KIM AND HIS INNER CIRCLE,
SMILING BROADLY, A RARE
APPARENTLY UNTOUCHED IMAGE.
>> AT SOME LEVEL THEY'RE TRYING
TO CAPTURE A BIT OF PERSONALITY.
HE'S THE ONLY ONE WHO IS SMILING
IN ALL THESE PICTURES.
MAYBE HE HAS REASON TO.
>> Reporter: ONE OF THE PHOTOS
IS A SURPRISE, OF A GENERAL SAID
BY SOUTH KOREAN OFFICIALS TO
HAVE BEEN EXECUTED IN FEBRUARY.
TURNS OUT HE IS A MEMBER OF THE
POWERFUL CENTRAL COMMITTEE, PART
OF THE PAGEANTRY, KIM JONG-UN'S
YOUNGER SISTER, SEEN COLLECTING
FLOWERS FOR HIM AT THE PARADE
FINALE.
SHE, TOO, HAS BEEN ELEVATED TO
THE CENTRAL COMMITTEE ACCORDING
TO THE NORTH KOREAN GOVERNMENT.
KIM JONG-UN IS BELIEVED TO BE
ONLY 28 YEARS OLD AND HAS
ENORMOUS INFLUENCE IN THE
CIRCLE.
ANALYSTS SAY SHE WORKS IN HER
BROTHER'S OFFICE, CONTROLS
ACCESS TO HIM, MANAGES ALL HISSY
VENTS.
>> SHE'S GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL THE SCHEDULE GOES RIGHT, AND
ALL THE RIGHT PEOPLE SEE HIM.
SHE'S DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROPAGANDA ROLE.
SO REALLY SHOWING, SHOW CASING
KIM JONG-UN'S IMAGE.
>> Reporter: EXPERTS SAY HE HAS
AN OLDER SISTER WHO ALSO HAS HIS
YEAR.
SHE OPERATES IN THE SHADOWS.
THERE ARE NO VERIFIABLE PICTURES
OF HER, SHE'S SEEN AS A MENTOR
TO KIM JONG-UN AND HIS YOUNGER
SISTER, CRUCIAL TO HELPING THEM
DEVELOP RELATIONSHIPS INSIDE THE
TREACHEROUS HALLS OF POWER.
>> HE'S GOT TO BE PEOPLE WHO HE
FEELS ARE GOING TO BE
UNQUESTIONABLY LOYAL TO HIM, WHO
ARE NOT GOING TO UNDERMINE HIM,
WHO ARE GOING TO PROTECT HIM
UNDER ALL CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> Reporter: KIM HAS TWO OTHER
SIBLINGS WHO HE AND HIS FATHER
HAVE NOT TRUSTED TO BE CLOSE TO
HIM.
THE OLDER BROTHERS WERE PASSED
OVER FOR TOP LEADERSHIP ROLE,
SAID TO BE NOT INTERESTED IN THE
JOB.
WHY HAVEN'T THEY GOTTEN OTHER
TOP POSITIONS?
UNLIKE THEIR SISTERS, ANALYSTS
SAY, THESE TWO ARE SEEN AS
POTENTIAL THREATS TO KIM
JONG-UN, POSSIBLY CREATING RIVAL
POWER FACTIONS WITHIN THE